James Gunn has cast his Superman and his
Lois Lane David coron swept and Rachel
Brosnahan will be playing the respective
roles I'm not especially familiar with
either of these actors David Corn sweat
actually appears to be pretty close to
an unknown the parts on his IMDb page is
like one episode appearances and uh most
TV shows and characters in movies who
didn't even get proper names Rachel
Brosnahan on the other hand actually is
a bit more established she has been
playing the lead in The Marvelous Mrs
maisel for some years now now this
basically is in line with what James
Gunn has implied wanting this to deal
with kind of a younger uh Superman than
maybe people were expecting as at the
time of Presumed shooting they will both
be in their 30s with David Corn sweat
having only recently gotten there so
this is what we've got I don't have too
much of opinion because I'm not familiar
with either of them but here we are